this Airfield was once a strategic base
for Russian forces in Herson now Drone
footage taken after mosca's retreat in
early November shows that litter would
destroyed military equipment
piles of damaged seemingly unusable
Hardware sit on roads and Fields
offering Clues on Russia's strategy for
the next phase of the war
after losing her son Russia launched
missile attacks on Kiev and other
Ukrainian cities but along the front
lines in southern Ukraine Moscow is
focusing on reinforcing its positions
further east
so here's how images from this liberated
City help understand Russia's military
shift ahead of the winter when extremely
cold weather complicates operations
first let's look at this Airfield which
was used by Russian forces as a base for
its Aviation
these satellite images show how Moscow
housed helicopters trucks and other
military equipment here after occupying
Harrison in the early days of the war
the resources were meant to support the
Army's attacks in a push to conquer new
territory
however they were also exposed to
Ukrainian attacks that inflicted heavy
damage on equipment like these
helicopters that were hit as early as
March
and in recent months analysts say those
positions had become untenable as
Ukraine also hit supply lines and
infrastructure like this bridge making
it difficult for Russia to send
ammunition and in the long term support
any attacks
Russia's defense minister announced the
withdrawal from the area on November 9th
saying the safety and well-being of
military personnel was Paramount
but weeks before that announcement
Russia had already started to withdraw
its soldiers as it also evacuates
civilians that's according to analysts
and her son residents who say they
noticed unusual movements since October
troops took the time to move equipment
across the Juniper River towards
territory Russia controls in the east
the process appeared to be more
organized than earlier Russian retreats
in the Harkey region for example Russian
troops were forced down in September
after a surprise counter-attack by
Ukraine back then the Ukrainian Army
took over tanks howitzers and many other
functioning weapons
but in her son the vast majority of the
gear Left Behind appeared to be heavily
damaged pointing to what analysts say is
a pre-planned operation although
Ukrainian propaganda videos promoted the
idea that Russia had abandoned valuable
tanks and ammunition defense analysts
and wsj reporters in Harrison said the
number of recovered weapons appears to
be minimal
weapons experts who review these images
say they believe some tanks and armored
vehicles were intentionally destroyed by
Russian forces before they fled so they
couldn't be used by the ukrainians
for Ukraine taking back her song was an
important symbolic Victory military
analysts say Moscow has paired some
losses and has the possibility to
reorganize and redeploy to other fronts
in the East where it is also struggled
to make gains for both armies analyst
States also a chance to replenish their
armories and stock up supplies as
temperatures fall and combat conditions
become more challenging